headlights aren't just functional
they're often the first design feature
that catches the eye of a potential
buyer
unlike the metal and glass versions of
the past today's headlights are made of
durable plastic that can be creatively
molded into a multitude of shapes most
of the headlights components are made of
injection molded plastic the machine
melts plastic pellets into a gooey
liquid then shoots it into a mold for
the specific part when the lens comes
out they wipe it down with an
anti-static cloth and inspect the
surface meticulously next a robot sprays
the lens with the protective coating
this will prevent scratches chips or
yellowing from exposure to ultraviolet
rays
they run the lens through a tunnel oven
to cure it
this component is the reflector for the
headlights main beam it's made of
fiberglass reinforced polyester a robot
sprays on a coat of primer now comes the
process that makes the reflector
reflective inside an aluminized chamber
a fixture rotates the reflector on its
own axis as well as around copper
electrodes at the center of the machine
an electrical charge to the copper
electrodes generates heat which
vaporizes that aluminum wire that's
wrapped around a spiral tungsten
filament the aluminum becomes a mist
that deposits evenly across the surface
of the reflector
now they assemble the headlight
beginning with the housing it's made of
injected molded polypropylene after
installing the reflector for the daytime
running light they screw in the
reflector for the turn signal it's made
of aluminized plastic then a robot
applies a sealant which prevents water
dust and insects from penetrating the
housing they place the assembly in a
lens binding machine
then they insert the main beam lens
securing these assemblies to each other
with screws next they screw in a halogen
bulb for the main beam reflector the
ball has two filaments for a high and
low beam then they add halogen bulbs for
the turn signal and daytime running
lights it's easy to change your burnt
out bulb in both designs you simply lift
the hood of the vehicle to access the
bulb from the rear of the headlight
housing